Bob Muller won't go away and Joe Biden
can't be found we will analyze the
former special counsels campaign to get
Congress to impeach Donald Trump then we
will try to locate the elusive 2020
presidential candidate a maniac lights
himself on fire outside the White House
to protest President Trump
New York magazine Marvel's that ugly
guys want to look better to get laid and
a conservative writer opens a massive
debate and very important debate on what
exactly we mean by conservatism finally
the mailbag I'm Michael Knowles and this
is the Michael Knowles show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we have an inordinate amount of things
to get to today not the least of which
is the former Special Counsel Bob Muller
basically teeing up a campaign for
Congress to impeach Trump totally
showing his partisan cards totally and
finally showing he's not acting in good
faith even though a lot of us gave him
the benefit of the doubt but first think
about the peace of mind that you have by
being prepared for any emergency
it's just that sort of thing you've got
that low-level stress you worry gosh can
I take care of my family if there's an
emergency what will happen wise company
takes an innovative approach by
providing dependable simple and
affordable freeze-dried food for
emergency preparedness and outdoor use
wise company meals are designed to
protect your most valuable asset your
family when government resources are
strained it can be days if not weeks
before you can get to fresh food and
water we've seen this happen around the
country natural disasters people are
trapped don't let yourself get stuck in
that position and don't let yourself
worry about that just even if it's a
low-grade worry just right now go over
to wise company and just be prepared get
their food all their ingredients our
chef prepared internally by wise company
wise emergency food is an investment in
peace of mind for your family buy it
forget it store it you'll be prepared
you don't need to worry about your
family this week my listeners get any
wise emergency or outdoor food product
at an extra 25 percent off the lowest
marked price at wise food storage calm
when entering Knowles Canada will UL es
at checkout or by calling eight five
five four five three two nine four five
plus shipping is free wise has a ninety
day no questions asked return policy
there is no risk in taking the
initiative to get yourself and your
family more prepared today that is wise
food storage calm promo code Knowles k
no wles to get any wise emergency or
outdoor food product at an extra twenty
five percent off and free shipping and
then you get peace of mind and who could
put a price on that
go do it today all right Bob Muller I
can't defend him at all anymore I tried
to be fair I tried to be balanced I
tried to say maybe he's not a partisan
hack he is he showed his partisan cards
it was unnecessary
unfortunate yesterday the former special
counsel before he finally left
he held a big press conference to try to
frame President Trump as a sort of
criminal to try to frame the what will
happen now politically in Congress as
the Congress considers impeachment here
is the key part of the press conference
after that investigation if we had had
confidence that the president clearly
did not commit a crime we would have
said so we did not however make a
determination as to whether the
President did commit a crime the
introduction to the volume two of our
report explains that decision it
explains that under long-standing
department policy a president president
cannot be charged with a federal crime
while he is in office that is
unconstitutional even if the charge is
kept under seal and hidden from public
view that too is prohibited the special
counsels office is part of the
Department of Justice and by regulation
it was bound by that department policy
charging the president with a crime was
therefore not an option we could
consider the department's written
opinion explaining the policy makes
several important points that further
informed our handling of the obstruction
investigation what Muller did here is so
so wrong it is so beyond the scope of
his job it is so wrong to politicize the
federal government in this way so what
exactly did he do the key takeaway the
big line from this press conference is
that Muller is not quote confident that
the president clearly did not commit a
crime since when has that been the
standard of justice in this country
since when has that been the standard of
innocence or guilt in in this country
typically we would say that you are
innocent until proven guilty now
according to Bob Muller you are guilty
until he is confident that you
did not commit a crime that's the
implication here Bob Muller is not
confident that the president did not
clearly commit a crime oh okay
so did he commit a crime well no no
we're not going to conclude that so
you're not saying he committed a crime
right I'm not saying he committed a
crime so then you're saying there's
there's no actionable evidence that he
committed a crime well yeah but I'm not
confident that he didn't clearly commit
a crime that he clearly did not commit a
crime what is this all about
now his defense here he comes on and
says that under DOJ guidelines he can't
indict the president okay so then why
was he investigating this obstruction in
the first place why did he write 200
pages about obstruction in the first
place and I know this is very confusing
it's going on for years now we hear
about the Muller investigation the
Russia the collusion what was Bob Muller
tasked with doing in the first place the
entire reason the Bob Muller was
appointed the entire reason he has this
investigation is to determine the extent
of Russian interference in the 2016
election which he did by the way he
indicted a bunch of Russians he found
certain companies in Russia that were
working to shift the balance of the 2016
election actually working for multiple
candidates or working rather to advance
multiple candidates so his job was to
identify Russian interference
he says explicitly he is not allowed to
indict a sitting president so if he's
not allowed to do that then he's not
going to conclude that a president
committed a crime so then really he
shouldn't have been investigating this
in the first place
he overstepped the bounds of his office
why did he investigate obstruction if he
couldn't do anything with him he
investigated obstruction because he
hates Donald Trump and he really wishes
that Donald Trump didn't win in 2016 and
he wants to do the work of congressional
Democrats for them to help them impeach
him what else could it have been
what else could he have been doing he
can't take any action even if he did
find sufficient evidence of the crime of
collusion which by the way the Attorney
General William Bar and the Deputy
Attorney General rod Rosenstein did not
find evidence of obstruction they did
not find sufficient evidence of
obstruction to act so even on that front
they declared the DOJ declared there
wasn't sufficient evidence now what
really happened here Muller punted on
the question of obstruction then the
Attorney General and the Deputy Attorney
General came to the conclusion as was
their job and the conclusion they came
to was that there was not sufficient
evidence of obstruction some people are
saying well why didn't they leave the
question open because the Department of
Justice is not a freshman seminar at a
college in the middle of America the
purpose of the Department of Justice is
not to foster intellectual debate and
engage in hypotheticals and just leave
questions out there and you can form
your own conclusions the Department of
Justice is the Department of Justice it
is there to prosecute it is there to
effect justice you don't get to just
leave academic questions hanging in the
air you have to come to a conclusion so
they came to the conclusion and Bob
Muller is really upset that the report
that he gave out did not have the
political effect that he obviously
wanted which was to hurt the president
so then what did he do he wrote a letter
he wrote an angry letter to William Barr
saying you misrepresented what my report
said so bar called him he said Bob why
the fancy letter if you had a problem
why not just call me what was your
problem with them because what Mulder
was saying is that Barr misrepresented
what Muller said in the report well the
reports out there you can read the
report yourself I've read the report
many other people have read the report
what did the report say did Barr
misrepresent it no in that first letter
you'll remember when the Muller report
came in
William Barr clearly said that Muller
did not exonerate Trump on obstruction
one way or the other he did not
come to a conclusion one way or the
other there was no new information in
this press conference this press
conference the only headline the only
thing that Muller was trying to say is
that if I had found if I was fully
convinced that President Trump did not
commit the crime of obstruction I would
have said so right you said that in the
report we all read it not only did you
say it in the report weeks ago William
bar quoted you as saying that in his
first letter on the subject weeks ago
there was no news Bob Muller is just
angry and petulant because the report
didn't begin the end of the Trump
administration and so he's trying to egg
Congress along to impeach him President
Trump for his part responded in a
typically trumpian way he made some
great points and then he made some what
seemed to be very unhelpful points on an
impromptu press conference not a nice
one he wasn't he wasn't happy with what
I did and I don't blame him but I had to
do it because that was the right thing
to do but I had a business dispute and
he loves cuoco me you look at the
relationship to those two so whether
it's love or deep like but he should he
was conflicted look Robert Muller should
have never been chosen because he wanted
the FBI job and he didn't get it and the
next day he was picked as special
counsel so you tell somebody I'm sorry
you can't have the job and then after
you say that he's going to make a ruling
on you it doesn't work that way
plus we had a business dispute plus his
relationship with Comey
was extraordinary so what does President
Trump doing here he is reaching into a
pot on the stove and he is pulling out a
big handful of spaghetti and he is
throwing it at the wall he's giving a
bunch of facts about Robert Muller that
apparently have no bearing on the
question but he's just doing it to
create the sense that Muller was always
compromised
which by the way is true just not for
the reasons that President Trump says so
president Trump says that Comey
that Muller rather wanted the FBI
director job maybe he did he did meet
with President Trump so it's very
possible that he did he then says that's
the reason why he shouldn't have been
appointed I don't know about that then
he says they were in a business dispute
I don't know the nature of the business
dispute but okay well I do what does
that mean then he says he really likes
James Comey it does appear that he had a
very good relationship with James Comey
okay fine but he's throwing all these
things out there which one is it that
actually shows why Bob Muller was unfit
for this job he eventually comes to the
point after throwing the spaghetti at
the ball we'll get to that in a second
but first speaking of firing things off
we the people holsters offer custom-made
holsters all produced in the USA they
are super cool I love that they are
produced in the USA and consequently
they are extremely high quality they
designed their own holsters in-house
that means they don't use any
third-party molds for their holsters
instead they design every unique mold in
Las Vegas in order to best fit each and
every firearm perfectly they are
constantly updating their designs
they're adding new designs every month
lets them stay up to date on the newest
models that come out they have their own
3d design team they measure every micro
millimeter of their guns to ensure the
perfect fit that you cannot get better
quality than this and the designs are
extremely cool too they print their
designs in-house The Thin Blue Line
Constitution camo American flag and they
more and more each month best part of
all We the People holsters start at just
37 bucks apiece
every holster ships with a lifetime
guarantee
how many holsters can you say that about
every holster ships for free if it's not
a perfect fit send it back for a refund
I love them and especially look you want
to protect your gun because you want to
protect yourself so make sure that you
you don't cheap out on the holster and
you don't get some shoddy quality make
sure that you get the best quality and
you can get it right now if you're a
listener of the Michael Noel's show if
you go to We the People holsters dot-com
slash Knowles you enter the promo code
Knowles at checkout you will get 10
bucks off your first holster that is as
low as 37 bucks
and the shipping is free and then you
get another $10 off using my promo code
that's pretty good
we the people holsters dot-com slash
Noel's Kano wles
promo code Knowles Kanna wles at
checkout for $10 off so you down to what
27 bucks don't be foolish go get it
today so president Trump throw spaghetti
at the wall because of because
legitimately because of this outrageous
press conference from Bob Muller then he
comes to the better point in his
response eventually somebody that didn't
get a job that I requested that he
wanted very badly and then he was
appointed and despite that and despite
40 million dollars 18 Trump haters
including people that work for Hillary
Clinton and some of the worst human
beings on earth they got nothing it's
pretty amazing this is it I love the
because than some of the worst human
beings on earth it's fair enough you
know that's the real point Bob Muller in
his actions appears to be a committed
never Trump er not a guy who had issues
with Trump maybe voted for maybe didn't
but you know okay moves on this is a guy
who staffed his investigation with
people committed to overturning the 2016
election with people where we found
their text messages and they say we're
gonna cheat we're gonna use the power of
the state we are going to rig everything
to stop Trump from being elected
president that is the problem he that is
why he was compromised that's why this
investigation was compromised we have
tried to be fair to him we have tried to
give him the benefit of the depth this
press conference I think totally blew
that out of the water and I'm not alone
in thinking this the some of the
greatest legal minds in the country
agree with this not just committed
Republicans but people who have been
lifelong Democrats lifelong civil
libertarians guys like our friend Alan
Dershowitz Alan Dershowitz wrote out
quote until today I've defended Muller
against the accusations that he's a
partisan I did not believe that he
personal
favor either the Democrats or the
Republicans or had a point of view on
whether President Trump should be
impeached but I have now changed my mind
by putting his thumb
indeed his elbow on the scale of Justice
in favor of impeachment based on
obstruction of justice Muller has
revealed his partisan bias
he has distorted the critical role of a
prosecutor in our justice system
exactly right people all the time
complain about Donald Trump undermining
our institutions our our political
process no people whose staff absurd
investigations with committed never
Trump errs and committed partisans who
brag about using the levers of power and
the federal government to overturn a
presidential election those are the guys
undermining our institutions those are
the guys who are undermining our
political processes much more so and
much more egregiously with Donald Trump
at least Donald Trump when he
exaggerates when he says things that
aren't true when he boasts when he brags
when he goes goes all the way out there
at least you know what you're getting at
least he's sort of honest about it but
these guys Robert Muller unimpeachable
the most serious respectable man in the
country he wears his tie all nice he has
a very serious face he has worked in the
federal government his whole life and
then he staffs his entire investigation
with partisans and and people who were
committed to overturning the election
and then when he doesn't get his
political way he hosts an outrageous
press conference that just reiterates
his points and eggs on Congress to
impeach that's the guy that's the
problem because he's not honest about it
he's not honest about his goals same
thing with the people that he staffed
same thing with the people egging him on
that that's the real problem after this
press conference it's very hard to
conclude that Bob Muller has been acting
in good faith now something you would
say why do you hold the press conference
maybe he did it as a last word because
he doesn't want to testify before
Congress because he doesn't want to
inject himself into politics if that
were true he could have just written
another letter if that were true if what
he said there is true this is my final
statement and my my Muller report is
my testimony if that were true he could
have written that in a letter could have
texted it he could have done anything
other than hold this press conference
and all but beg Congress to impeach
maybe he thinks William Barr
misrepresented his findings well except
that Muller didn't say anything in that
press conference that Barr didn't write
in his report about the report he's
campaigning to get Congress to impeach
he's politicizing what is supposed to be
the least political office in the
federal government and it's too bad at
least one man though was even less in
control of his emotions than Bob Miller
was yesterday for those watching this is
a little hard to watch a man set himself
on fire outside the White House to
protest President Trump do what the it's
not a stunt
dude it's on stun this guy's caring he's
burn himself a lot nobody goes in first
responders extinguished him they took
him to the hospital very sadly the man
died the reason I bring it up at all is
is because of the reaction to it there
were a lot of people on Twitter calling
him brave saying this is so brave this
is Wow look at this brave and courageous
man setting himself there's nothing
brave about this this is mental illness
what you're looking at is mental illness
33 year old
Arnab go p-- days from Bethesda Maryland
he had been reported missing earlier in
the day by his family who said that they
were concerned for his physical and
emotional welfare he then went out lit
himself on fire and killed himself he
committed suicide and some people are
calling him brave for this this is
mental illness
no one should call it brave I'm certain
the guy had underlying madness and I'm
certain that that madness was
exacerbated by hysteria about the
president by hysteria that the president
is a fascist murderer genocide erased
stooge of russia he's destroying the
whole world because of that hysteria it
would appear that his mental illness got
worse I'm not blaming the media outlets
that fan the flames of that hysteria and
the political activists who fanned the
flames of that hysteria I'm not blaming
them for his death but it is undeniably
it seems the case that that climate that
hysteria contributed to this mental
illness which should raise questions for
us about how we discuss this president
I'm not you can be vigorously critical
absolutely but some of the excesses that
we've seen for
years seem to be just that they seem to
be excessive however what people do have
responsibility for is their reaction to
this there's nothing brave about what he
did
there's nothing Courageous about what he
did there's nothing to be encouraged
about what he did it's mental illness we
should pray for the guy we should pray
for his family it's awful and we should
hopefully and all the smoke of this guy
going up in flames we should try to see
politics with a little clarity and and
to blow away the fogs of hysteria
speaking of clarity and hysteria there
is a major news story in New York
Magazine about in cells I don't know if
you've heard about in cells in cells are
the involuntarily celibate it's a it's a
phrase referring to guys who are ugly
and they they can't get laid and as a
result they hate women and now this
story is that they are getting plastic
surgery to make themselves look better
so the opposite of an in cell in this
culture is is a Chad that's their word
for guys who look good Chad's and New
York magazine has this headline how many
bones would you break to get laid the
article begins in cells are going under
the knife to reshape their faces and
they're dating prospects the posters
called themselves in cells short for
involuntarily celibate on one forum
where a commenter truth for live posted
its lookism which succeeded a forum
called [ __ ] hate there were 10,000
registered users they were on other
websites too although it's impossible to
know who was posting on multiple
accounts in cells called women like the
one truth for lie had hired Stacy's
alpha men had a name to they were called
Chad's so this is this culture they're
describing pretty bizarre culture
obviously but I just want to point out
this headline how many bones would you
break to get laid New York Magazine is
just viciously mocking these guys even
in the headline because they're getting
plastic surgery to look better okay
perfectly fair to criticize people who
get cosmetic surgery just to look a
little bit nicer would you use that same
headline to talk about a girl who gets a
nose job
I don't remember New York Magazine
saying how many bones would you
to get laid ladies these desperate women
with big noses are getting nose jobs and
and breast augmentation what a bunch of
weird losers that's a little bit of a
double standard here now obviously these
insell guys are lunatics as well and
they should shake out of it they they go
on the article right so you know those
guys who are quote praised day and night
for their top-tier genetics making a
boatload I'll change the word of money
getting insane amounts of validation
never having to worry about paying the
rent or any of that BS all they think
about is their next football match and
coming home and having a threesome with
two supermodels supermodels that puke at
the thought of them touching you that's
how one in cell with a Pepe frog is this
avatar described Chad's so obviously a
lot of this culture I think is trolling
like everything on the Internet it's
trolling they're exaggerating they're
using these kind of terms in an ironic
way they're using memes in an ironic way
I suspect they're even using misogyny in
an ironic way lots of the time however
if you live in iron if you are being
ironic all of the time then there's no
such thing as irony that's just what
you're doing if you troll all of the
time that's just who you are
you just have become the troll you have
become Pepe the Frog and the the issue
here to within cell culture is the same
poison that is affecting all of the
culture which is materialism which is
that we are just our bodies that our
physical features are that's all that we
are that's all that make us up and
therefore we can hopefully try to change
them forever and make them better now
what these guys seem to miss they say if
you're ugly you're not ever gonna have
sex with a woman I know I personally
know ugly rich guys who sleep with
beautiful women all the time it's this
try don't know why it's something
there's something very physically
attractive about a wad of cash in
somebody's pocket people who are very
successful people who have good careers
people who get famous even if they're
ugly even if they're not that rich there
are other shallow attributes that also
attract women so I think the premise of
in cell culture that if you're ugly
you're never
to sleep with a woman that premise is
demonstrably false and the the bigger
problem then the topic of this essay is
is a major problem in our culture the
idea that we are just our physical
bodies and further the idea that we can
just endlessly change ourselves
endlessly augment our physicality and
that will somehow make us feel better
that will somehow make us have a better
life
this is the same logic of transgenderism
it's exactly the same logic it's this
it's the same logic that tells us that
we can not only define ourselves we can
thereby define reality by chopping off
this part of us or reach angel bun and
that is not true and this actually ties
in to a major political story on the
right today which is a big debate that
has broken out between traditionalist
conservatives and more classically
liberal conservatives can you take
Liberty to its logical conclusion
forever and redefine everything and just
maximize individual autonomy or is there
something that restrains us something
that holds us back morality religion
culture I'll get to that in a second but
first plus we'll get to the mailbag
first you got to go to daily wire.com
you get everything you got the whole
daily wire crew me ben shapiro andrew
Clavin matt walsh another kingdom
questions in the mailbag questions
backstage and the leftist here's tumblr
but you got to go to daily wire calm be
right back we got a lot more
all right before we get to the mailbag
before we get to questions of the rift
and the conservative movement we have
got to find out where Joe Biden is has
anybody seen Joe Biden is Joe Biden
should we file a missing-persons report
for Joe Biden he didn't participate in
any Memorial Day ceremonies on Monday
this is one of the biggest campaign
events of the campaign season going to a
Memorial Day ceremony Pete and Bernie
were in New Hampshire Amy Klobuchar was
in Minneapolis Elizabeth Warren was in
Iowa Camela did a video on Memorial Day
Biden nowhere to be found
why not because Joe Biden thinks he's
going to get the nomination by default
Joe Biden thinks he's pulling way ahead
of everybody 15 points ahead of Bernie
he's he's 30 points ahead of other
competitors he's killing it in the race
right now so he says the best way that I
can maintain that lead is by pulling
back is by not showing myself why
because Joe Biden is the most gaffe
prone politician in the entire country
so for Joe Biden being in public is a
liability for most politicians being in
public is helpful when putas jej goes on
TV people like him more he gets more
name recognition he does better for Joe
Biden people like him the most that they
will ever like him right now when he
opens his mouth when he talks when he
when he acts in public people like him
less so he's trying to hide this is very
difficult for him I can't remember
anyone who just got the nomination by
playing it really safe and hiding out
which President did that happened
obviously not Donald Trump obviously not
Barack Obama certainly not george w bush
not Bill Clinton not what this doesn't
work you've got to go for it you've got
to grab hold of something you have to
offer people something if you are the
liability how do you expect to get the
nomination I know that Joe Biden has a
big lead right now we haven't even had
the first debate he's going to have to
open his mouth eventually better to go
on the offense better to define yourself
and and if you being in public is the
big liability presidents have to be in
public presidential candidates need to
be in public a lot that's probably not
going to work out very well for him we
have an enormous debate opening up on
the right between traditional
conservatives social conservatives I
guess you would say and classical
liberals the people who who believe that
the most important thing the main thing
that matters is individual liberty
maximizing individual liberty
unfortunately we don't have time to get
to it today so we're gonna have to get
to that tomorrow tuned back and we will
discuss it because it's a very important
debate and people are taking very strong
sides and and will try to analyze what
it really means today however we don't
have time for that because we have to
get to the mailbag so let's get to it
let's get through as many as we can from
Michael great name hello Michael
I too am a fellow Michael what are your
thoughts about men wearing earrings in
professional settings I appreciate your
thoughts if you are a rock musician or a
pirate you can wear earrings in a
professional setting if you are a man in
any other profession you cannot wear an
earring in the office or anywhere else
from Michael also Michael hi Michael I'm
wondering about your thoughts on why
most of the prominent Democrats happen
to be baby boomers does this bode well
from the Democratic Party no that
doesn't bode well at all for them I have
noticed this obviously Joe Biden is
leading the pack right now Bernie
Sanders is right after him Hillary
Clinton's for the most prominent
Democrat in the country they're boomers
that's true and I think the reason why
boomers are trending Democratic is
because the Democratic Party is
embracing past ideas old ideas ideas
that have been rejected the the baby
boomers were the hippies right they grew
up they sort of became the hippies and
they they broke down so many cultural
institutions I know
it's nostalgic to look back and say oh
the past used to be better and now it's
much worse something really did change
in the late nineteen
in 70s and then up through the 80s
something really fundamentally cracked
in the culture and this had a lot to do
with the rise of second wave feminism
had a lot to do with the sexual
revolution had a lot to do with the
cultural revolutions that happened not
just in the US but all around the world
and what it led to was an acceleration
away from traditional culture so you you
saw on university campuses hollowing out
of the curriculum saying hey hey ho ho
Western Civ has got to go as they march
through the campuses sitting in shutting
down classrooms
it was the left's long march through the
institution's Hollywood basically falls
apart in the 1960s and 1970s
all the great old movies gone now movies
have an explicitly leftist political
agenda and almost a uniformly leftist
political agenda it's all just about
deconstruction breaking down that's what
has defined the baby boomers that is
what now defines the Democratic Party
and so even young Democrats have
embraced these sorts of ideologies I
think that's why you see it there and
the alternative is is the opposite of
destruction its conservatism and it's is
building things back up and it's
harkening back to our traditions our
political the cultural and religious
traditions I hope that answers it from
Michael another Michael goodness
gracious
hello Michael I have recently had an
argument thrown at me against abortion
that I wonder how you would respond to
the person said that they don't like
guns but don't want our right to them
taken away I'm curious how you would
respond to this argument sincerely
Michael
the idea being I don't like guns but I
don't want people's political right to a
gun taken away therefore I don't like
abortion but I also don't want people's
political right to an abortion taken
away so the difference here are the most
basic difference is that there is a
constitutional right to a gun you have
the Second Amendment the right to keep
and bear arms there is no constitutional
right to an abortion even the Supreme
Court jurists who invented that right in
Roe vs. Wade
more or less admitted that it wasn't in
the Constitution
they said well maybe you can find it in
part in the ninth amendment or maybe you
can find it in the 14th doesn't really
matter now there's a right to an
abortion so there is no right it would
be one reason the other reason is that
guns exist to protect life that's the
the purpose of the Second Amendment is
to protect your life in your life your
family's life and your liberty against
tyranny the purpose of abortion is to
end life it's to kill life so it's a
it's a mother killing her child or an
abortion doctor killing a mother's child
the other aspect here is if you're
arguing from st. natural rights which
people do in America a lie you got life
liberty and the pursuit of happiness
so we protect our Liberty of course life
comes first because without life you
can't have a Liberty without liberty you
can't have the pursuit of happiness or
the pursuit of property I I've never
heard that argument before that you
bring up I don't think it has any merit
at all and I think there are a number of
ways that you can answer it pretty
succinctly from Joshua would you say
that there is a correlation between not
knowing American laws and rights with
leaning politically to the left
absolutely that is absolutely the case
and and you see it not just on a micro
level so individuals who are less aware
of our Constitution and our laws in our
history lean more left although they do
you also see this on a social level so
in recent decades people's knowledge of
American history American civics
American government has dramatically
decreased most Americans can't name all
three branches of government most people
can't identify what the First Amendment
does and as that has happened the
country has moved to the left
even though conservatives and
Republicans win some elections here are
they're the country and the culture
overall has moved to the left a country
cannot be stupid and remain free a
country cannot be ignorant and remain
free and so what the left is done is
hollowed out education and hollowed out
our own civics and even in our history
departments turned our history against
us rewritten certain aspects of history
deleted whole swaths
history taken away context from history
and so people graduate ignorant and they
become more susceptible to ideologies
that are fundamentally unamerican from
coal hey Michael my girlfriend is
worried my traditional values will rob
her of her autonomy
she holds similar values to me but we
were both raised in San Francisco so our
conservative values have marked us out
like black sheep amidst friends how do I
counter the leftist narrative that I am
a chauvinist or a misogynist how do I
show I still unequivocally consider my
girlfriend equal thank you Cole well the
first way is you probably have a better
relationship with your girlfriend than
most of these lefty friends that's just
gonna be my guess so the best way to
show it is to just have a great
relationship and it is certainly the
case I have seen it practically
personally I've seen it anecdotally with
friends and statistics socially bear it
out people who are in traditional
romantic relationships are much happier
they're much better off the New York
Times had to admit this the other day
the happiest wife in America the
happiest category of life or religious
conservative lives not religious
liberals not your religious conservative
or the traditional types and
specifically traditional conservatives
are the happiest wives that is one way
to do it the other way is to show that
actually feminism is pretty anti woman
and traditional gender roles are pretty
Pro woman what do I mean by that
feminism tells women that the only way
that they can be good and valuable and
worthwhile is to act more like men dress
like men go to the same jobs that men go
to engage in the same sort of sexual
behavior that men engage in take the
same attitude towards sex that men do
just be like men they're saying
femininity is valueless worthless but
masculinity is very valuable and so
women need to be like men that's what
feminism says what traditional gender
roles teach is that men and women are
spiritually equal
even though they are different
indistinct the the most obvious example
of this is Adam and Eve Eve comes from
Adam's rib God reaches into Adam pulls
out his rib and creates Eve this does
not make Eve subservient to Adam this
does not make even lesser than Adam if
God had pulled out part of Adam's hair
from the top of Adam's body that would
make Eve better than Adam if God had
pulled Eve from his big toe that would
make Eve less than Adam she pulls Eve he
pulls Eve rather he pulls her right from
the center of Adam that is to say right
in the middle his rib woman is
spiritually equal to man albeit
different and and and in different ways
that's the traditional view I suspect
that's the view you're talking about
that is the far more defensible view of
the genders than modern feminism which
which is the most anti woman theory that
we've yet devised from Ken how do we
keep our cool when dealing with the
emotions of the left I have many friends
who base their decisions off of emotions
rather than logical reasoning how does
one combat this without getting
emotional himself
I talked to left wingers all the time I
very rarely become emotional because I'm
confident in my views and I can defend
my views and they can't defend their
views people get emotional in political
discussion when they feel that they're
wrong they get emotional and political
discussion when they can't quite defend
what they're saying so they get really
worked up and they shriek and they yell
and they scream no and they wear the
pink hats and they do all of that when
you're confident about what you think
you just explain to them why they're
wrong they say well what about this you
say good good point but this is why
that's wrong well but what about this
okay fine good point but this is why
that's wrong so I I rarely get worked up
what's the point of getting worked up
emotionally you can be passionate about
what you believe
you can be firm about what you believe
but that's how I would deal with it the
crazier they get the cooler that you
would be because possibly you could
convince them but what you do 99% of the
time is you just make them look like
complete lunatics and you look like the
same guy and that helps us win helps us
win the culture it helps us win
elections from Daniel hi Michael I'd
like to know why the mothers and fathers
aren't liable for getting an abortion my
gut tells me they shouldn't be
criminally liable only the doctors
should be but what's a good argument for
this thanks Daniel I agree with that I
don't think that mothers who procure
abortions should be punished even though
I do think that doctors who perform
abortions should be punished why because
this legal system has told women now for
50 years that they have a constitutional
right to get an abortion so women have
been told for over a generation that
they have a legal constitutional right
to get an abortion they don't but that's
still pretty confusing the culture has
told them that they have a right to get
an abortion that abortion is not only
okay but that it's a good thing that you
should shout it from the rooftop how
wonderful that you can shout your
abortion and on a personal level women
get abortions for a variety of reasons
one of them is intense pressure pressure
from their boyfriend or the guy who got
them into trouble pressure from the
culture pressure maybe from their
parents pressure from their schools they
have a lot of pressure to go and kill
that baby and they've got a lot of
rationalizations for why it's not really
killing a baby and it's a really awful
thing I was at Planned Parenthood in
Philadelphia at that rally that Matt
Walsh put together I saw a woman walk
into Planned Parenthood she look happy
she wasn't skipping down the street she
didn't seem excited to go kill her child
she seemed distressed as as well she
should be because somewhere deep down
her conscience was telling her that she
shouldn't kill her baby but she was
distressed women are victims of abortion
as well they live with
lifelong regret I know multiple people
who have had abortions friends of mine
the ones that we've talked about it they
have immense regret Jane Roe the woman
who was in the case Roe versus Wade had
immense regret she actually didn't have
an abortion she actually had her child
but immense regret carried this guilt
with her the rest of her life that she
was part of killing all of these babies
because we know ultimately what it is
it's killing a baby so I think that
conservatives while eager for justice in
the case of abortion and eager to
prevent the deaths of a million babies a
year also much more than the left
understand human frailty and understand
the the complexity of the world and so
if we can stop abortion by through the
mechanisms of the law as we should and
punish the people who are removed who
don't have that pressure who don't face
all of those issues doctors who should
know better who took a Hippocratic oath
not to harm people first do no harm if
we can do it that way I think that's the
the wiser way to do it and and
ultimately a just way to do it from
Kendall hey Michael can you weigh in on
the argument going on between the more
Catholic than knowles and matt walsh
combined so Rob Amari and mr. ivory
tower David French it's funny that that
questions in there because that is a
story that I wanted to get to today and
will have to get to tomorrow the debate
between so Rob and David French is a
debate that has been bubbling among
conservatives for twenty years at a very
high level and has really been there the
whole time it's the debate between
conservatism traditionalism social
conservatism whatever you want to call
it and classical liberalism or people
who trend toward libertarianism or
people who say hey hands off it doesn't
matter we everything's neutral we want
pluralism we want oh that's the debate
that's happening
the reason the debate is happening now
is because both sides came together for
50 years 40 years I guess
from William F Buckley Jr bringing all
of these sides together the conservative
movement after World War 2 to fight
together against communism to fight
together against the Soviet Union so you
have the conservatives who were mostly
upset about atheism in communism and you
have the classical liberals who were
mostly upset about the collectivism of
communism and they came together because
they had a common enemy and then after
we vanquished that enemy of communism
the two sides broke apart again because
they had profound divisions that's the
debate that's being had right now if I
had to choose between the traditionalism
of Saurabh Amari and the liberalism
classical liberalism of David French I
would choose the traditionalism of so
Rob but the question is complicated and
we will get to that I guess tomorrow has
that for a cliffhanger in the meantime
I'm Michael Knowles this is the Michael
Knowles show I'll see you then
[Music]
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Rebecca dabka wits and directed by Mike
joiner executive producer Jeremy boring
senior producer Jonathan hey our
supervising producer is Mathis Glover
and our technical producer is Austin
Stevens edited by Dani D'Amico Audio is
mixed by Dylan case hair and makeup is
by Joshua alvera and our production
assistant is Nick Sheehan the Michael
Noel's show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 19
hey everyone its Andrew Klavan host of
the Andrew Clavin show once again an
investigator opens his fat mouth hoping
to take a shot at Donald Trump and
instead he blows up the Democrats maybe
they should appoint a special counsel to
investigate how Trump keeps doing that
that's on the Andrew Klavan show I'm
Andrew Clavin